welcome to this video a new part of the
endgame strategy serious yeah this video
shows the game between the white player
sweater sock the garage and black
playing our city's moose love we had two
well-known players grill coragem at the
time we are talking about 1953 it's from
the famous zurich candidates tournament
this game at the time the top player of
then Yugoslavia and he stayed the top
layer of Yugoslavia for really long time
yeah okay and smooth slow of course we
are talking about 1953 not yet world
champion but the world champion in the
making yeah he got the title of some
years later from what Vinick in this
game played in the candidates tournament
we start our yeah our our analysis
almost twenty i skipped them opening
move so they traded quite a number of
pieces and we come to this position
where a piece counted pont count gives
the result that black isn't porn up yeah
white has lost the pawn with some who
has some little tactic earlier on and
now we have an endgame
yeah two rooks each and annoyed and
black with this extra pawn should
definitely win this endgame but how
exactly to proceed black should be very
a very of counter play ideas from white
if you have extra material you should
try to limit the opponent's
possibilities as much as possible and
try to use your extra material to good
effect but without yeah bungling or
giving up any of any positional ground
black here should think of a
step-by-step plan to improve his
position and finally to get to make
something
as extra pawn it is black to move and
yeah what is the first step him a
defining factor of the positioners of
course the D file the open D file where
white is somewhat quicker and he's got
the rook on D 2 already and is ready to
play rook a to D 1 which would control
them the D fall and very reliably black
to move has clearly one best move and
this is rook F D 8 the first step here
should be to trade one pair of rooks if
you trade one pair of rooks you have a
very clear follow up what you need to do
is after group the one which is very
logical takes takes what you need to do
is here to make sure that white cannot
do anything threatening on the D how the
critical square is of course g7 the
seventh-ranked you should never ever
allow white to get there and yeah get
counter play with the rook black has a
very easy setup to achieve that and what
he does is using the King a very common
principle of course on the n chemists
that with the King not being under
immediate danger in most cases you
should use the King make it a useful
piece and here black can do that with
King f8 to b7 that's a very logical and
rewarding mini plan that black has one
point of the rook traders if you look at
this from the get-go one point of the
rook trade is to make this possible this
King activation as soon as possible if
we do it in another way I mean just what
else is there rook e8 or something white
will take the D file and it's not so
clear how we proceed we can put the King
on his heaven but at the end of it here
we can never move the knight do to rook
d7 so this does not make much sense it's
just much more logical to get the rooks
traded
and therefore allow a quick activation
of the king king e7 or King of Ed first
f3 king f7 ya f3 is designed to actually
allow this night to move yeah King f2
white also wants to centralize his King
for white it's very difficult to do
anything
you have three against two on the Queen
side so one tone more on the white side
but those pawns are not you're able to
really advance as black has this look on
c8 which always has a look at the c4
pawn so before it's never possible as c4
hangs very difficult for white to do
anything anything active but on the
other hand what should black do yeah if
we look at the pawn
distribution we see that black has five
taunts nor those five against three on
the Kings side so the material advantage
is on the Kings side and you should
normally play on the sight on that you
are stronger which means black really
should do something on the King side and
he does so right away h5 this is a good
move it gains space it prepares a
further advance or it can be the
follow-up can be further advanced by
let's say g5 and after which you have a
good choice with g4 or h4 h5 also makes
sure that Y never plays g4 g for wasn't
a very dangerous move but anyway we
limit White's possibilities considerably
and just improve our position without
giving any ground King III and g5 yeah
now black has advanced thus King side
but how do we how do we
proceed one idea is to just play h4 h4
has has yeah a dual-purpose if we get an
h4 if we just say white does nothing
movie plays rook h2 but let's say white
does nothing which is not so easy to do
really maybe Luke d1 then an idea can be
to just go h4 the idea is that we get a
passed pawn this is the first idea and
after the capture which is pretty much
mandatory hds g3 hangs and you don't
want to give like a protected passport
after this we have a natural follow-up
with the knight jumping to a form white
will definitely want to take and now we
have the passed pawn yeah let's say rook
h1 rook h8 this pawn is also supported
from the back by the rook the ideal
setup to support a person a further plan
can be the booth of this Knight let's
say to b7 and then go f59 f6 renewing
pressure on e4 this threat of H form
tempted White's to play rook edge to
attempted is the wrong word but yeah he
felt obliged to do that now what should
like to h4 was not that that easy to
play and one move that certainly can be
played is Ruka Jade intending to play at
form however smooth Slav played
differently
he played rook t8 this is one of those
little moves that just improve the
position a little bit and they ask white
okay what are you going to do what's
your idea it's a little bit of a waiting
move that improves our position without
giving anything away right now going to
rotate one until we come to an
interesting moment black definitely
could play another
improving move I could switch back to
the idea to play h5h form with them with
a passed pawn
however smooth Slav now played something
entirely different and as it turns out
his plan is very very effective and very
useful to remember he didn't go for H
fry at all but he went G for now this is
in fact a very strong move what's the
idea
the other idea is that black would like
to create a second weakness in White's
position the first weakness if you want
is the pawn deficit and what you want an
addition do you want something to attack
on the board and black has recognized
that after G form he will remove or
force the pawn to move on f3 if this
partner ever moves or takes on g4 as it
happens in the game if this pawn moves
then the e4 pawn all of a sudden it's
yes requiring protection the knight on
f6 then is pressurizing this and this
can also be supported by a possible rook
deform at the right moment yeah white
cannot really play F form if we look at
this quickly black will take Jack and
after G takes we can even start to march
the pawns yeah this is um this is too
much too connected passed pawns white
cannot even approach with the King do
tube Jack route d3 so you cannot play f4
and yeah letting him take on f3 is also
not a great great option so white
captured himself Knight takes d4 check
check
yeah it's better to take with the night
than to take with the pawn because the
pawn on g3 is easier to attack on g3
with the pawn being on edge 5 for
instance and looks like rook g8
and takes the pawn which is not possible
when there is a pawn on d4 Knight takes
d4 with a check kingi to plate yeah of
course now h5 is hanging and we don't
have anything immediately and so black
just retreated back to f6 now we see
that white has to pawn weaknesses
efore and g3 black on the other hand
only has h5 to worry about and this at
the moment is securely defended white
when King III and rook T form yeah just
activating this rook as much as possible
the pressure now only four means that
white cannot move the the knight on c3
which could be a source of counter play
with 95 for example white played rook
everyone he really does not have much to
do he could have played rook yeah yeah
where else if actually rook h4 hook h3
those kind of moves they they don't
really help much
yeah black plate Jack Knight g4 check
using the fact that at the moment the H
pawn is undefended to play now and this
is an interesting moment he now played
King f8 yeah why King f8 it's simply the
fact that the King on is 7 while not
being badly placed it is not serving any
special purpose there anymore at the
moment
notice that at the beginning we went
there - yeah - to occupy the center post
controlling d6 and d7 when white still
had the D far
but white now does not have the D fun
anymore this is not relevant
therefore and the King has nothing to do
on his 7 so what is s miss love doing is
regrouping the King 2 here and this is
of course a huge improvement if
you have the king over here you have
landed support to h5 and you support a
further advance of the pawns here it's
the wing where black has the two extra
pawns ultimately you want to you want to
advance them so the King is simply
improved now with King evade rook f3 and
King g7 yeah white not right rook d3
intending a rook trade yeah how should
black react very a very important moment
now as as it is all the time when there
are trades possible of course black here
cannot avoid the trade anymore and in
general we don't mind trading that much
because we are we are material of but we
still have to check how to exactly yeah
how to exactly conduct this trade
should we take ourselves on d3 or short
or should we let white take yeah if we
look at the structure a white capture on
d4 gives us a passed pawn on d4 and it
also gets rid of our double bond so it's
in fact much more desirable to have him
take on d4 than us taking on d3 this
means that black basically can now play
him yeah a free move like like a king
the king advanced was our idea however
in this concrete position we still have
to calculate if we go to g6 then white
can take and play Knight b5 and all of a
sudden there is a double attack and we
we lose some material back this is not
really necessary we can easily play
without this hassle and at the starting
position
start with King f6 if white now trades
and this happened in the game it's a
totally different story as we will see
yeah white the trade but you can you can
argue that this doesn't help him much
but what other moves don't as well I
like look every check you just go to to
g6 and continue from there so I
understand that big rich was fed up with
this and took on d4 yeah he took on
before he takes the 495 and now the big
difference it gets clear from f6 the
King can go to e5 so we have a much more
active King position now than with the
King on g6 and here we don't mind that
white can take a seven as after nine s7
has played in the game we can take any
form yeah white couldn't keep the pawn
of course this King move is easily
answered by the check so white took on
a7 we took on e4 and here we can see
that our centralized King we have much
more room here compared to white king is
on e to against on e4 and we have the D
pawn which is super dangerous in fact
here if you calculate deep enough you
can see that those two pawns are already
unstoppable it is relatively easy now
white plays Knight to c8 it really does
not don't matter it really does not
matter what what white place but yeah
here D 3 was played and it's a quite
funny situation if you look here it's
still absolutely important to pay
attention what's going on I mean this
sounds like like something very very
normal but you can still easily lose the
game IAM if you play 95 checkmate that's
very embarrassing
or alternatively this checkmate
so still you need to pay attention what
the other side is doing the way to win
of course is to start with the check
King b2 and now we need to focus on our
passports this should yeah
start start marching as soon as possible
so King before is the right move on
default so the King cannot easily be
checked and we have the e pawn running
now white try to c5 desperations was
there something else
yeah well we can look at night takes b6
but after then after that black wins
easily with transferring a Knight to e4
you don't even need the e pawn let's say
night f2 night a for night
if Jack we're just in time to get this
check in King moves and Knight takes and
now the H pawn is the decider white
knight sorts of totally off site and
cannot help at all if white plays Knight
d6 here then Knight e5 is a good answer
well we cover f7 and we get this again
Knight f3 check yeah to gain more gain
more space and ultimately advance our
points White has really no counter play
you know he can we can give this check
but we just go here you know note that
King f3 g3 is also very quickly coming
and the H pawn then can march the
current situation on the Queen side is
that white takes quite a lot of time
until there's any sort of dangerous porn
coming
yeah something like let's say a for
Kenya 3c5 takes 85 can we have many
pawns now 96 and we are stopping the
whole thing if white now is playing a 7
the H pawn is far far far too quick yeah
let's get back to the to the actual game
after King before
as mentioned gligar rich played c5 which
was just taken 96 and 95 this is very
similar to what we what we saw before in
the other line yeah black Kia is in
total control when after Knight b5 will
march to the Kings side it's a very
comparable if we get this going to f3 a
form it takes 85-page for a six ninety
six and we finally stop this loan source
of counter play to at the end win with
the inch pawn
yeah very easy window for black this is
a very instructive example of step by
step improving your position without
allowing any sort of counter play smooth
slope was step by step exchanging pieces
that were no help to him if we start
from the very beginning
yeah like notice that it is much easier
to play with one rook so he traded the
rook this allowed him to activate the
King get it to a7 which in turn makes
the position more flexible for black
note that you need to be only 7 for the
cube of the King to later check
faciliate this night this night moves by
now there was a rook on the 8th but
these are all little parts of
puzzle we don't need to rush things here
very important endgame and get more to
us of course
don't rush don't hurry yeah very often
it's not a matter of time what you need
to execute but of quality yes setting up
the right kind of the right kind of
position the key right kind of
improvement to push the opponent back
it's not about doing something super
quickly but to do the right things
execute it at the right time
yeah it's here we step a step see how
wide this is pushed back check we go
back and just have a final look at this
position if white is not going for Luke
t3 for the trade then he really will be
will be facing this pawn roller let's
say rook a3 just to complete the whole
thing if white is doing something like
that
ultimately f5 will follow and this means
that if for now it's a spot that white
cannot hold even if he lets say place
this yeah we of course we don't take on
e4 this would just reverse in how a pawn
structure we don't want the tribute pawn
but of course after rook f1 the much
better way to place Knight to f6 which
allows capture with the night keeping
the pawn structure healthy yeah here
white will lose a form or he needs to
take and after the trade we ultimately
get what we wanted or pawn structure now
has no double pawn and three against two
would be a very easy win like even can
consider route g4 or h4 to get to
connected passed pawns yeah so a good
example how to realize your material
advantage do it slowly yeah and yeah
think about possible counter play that's
more important than just pushing pawns
badly think of a good setup and good
trades that help your position yeah I
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching